particularité physique vous annoncer
quoi que tu sais faire moi je peux
rester immobile deux heures sur un
tabouret à écouter les conneries de
l'ormeau non là c'est pas lui ce soir
c'est montiel empêcher un peu déçu parce
que je ne peux pas prouver
j'ai bien bossé
c'est un bon niveau aussi tiens qu'est
ce que vous faites vous castaldi alors
moi je suis très doux avec mon corps
c'est vrai regardez bien dérisoire c'est
impressionnant
m me fais attention
[Rires]
cette hyper rennes c'est un autre la
premier qui n'auraient j'irai plus
maintenant rapport à d'habitude je pense
je suis hyper reggie wayne et 100
millions chefs n'ont pas du tout les
actuels et drôle en même temps mais sa
finesse des mots badji franchement qu'à
la fin de l'année peux faire ce que tu
pas de cas la fin de l'année après jeudi
soir de l'année tu as l'immunité
voilà et quelle immunité légale et quand
pourquoi il ya des bras d'honneur à la
limite si vous aviez pris ce qu'il a
pris j'ai encore des séquelles
benjamin ça va il a voulu on a fait une
potence un regard amical rien n'est
attendue mais voilà et mais benji check
peut-être pour ça d'ailleurs que voilà
je serai toujours là pour toi ce
week-end d'ailleurs c'est moi qui
t'amène parce qu'il va chez sa mère pour
noël en bretagne il ya plus de train et
c'est moi qui t'amène personne ne m'a
pas gêné qui l'amène personnellement
voiture ouais mon chéri on ne me les
pose je le laisse là bas il fait sa vie
et anglet je lui donne son petit sac ces
petits choco bn
je sens qu'il et puis je connais à
chercher dans deux semaines laquelle de
vos voitures c'est bien être et yonne je
sais le faire comme ça c'est comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment comment peut se dire ouais bien
ce soir chéri j'ai un truc de ouf duras
est en suspens je peux rester 40 minutes
en suspens sur les cuisses away sur les
motos taxis par exemple et ce marché 44
km d'affilée puisque je l'éprouvé en
faisant la saintélyon et à part ça moi
mais mérité ces messieurs mes bras je
vous rappelle à wave élégant jeudi me
jean michel maire c'est quoi ta partie
car oui j'arrive à faire un double avec
ma [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais non ou que ce que je verrai rire à
ses blagues
ils sortiront ça tu sors aller qu'est ce
que vous savez faire vous fabien à
fabien n'est pas là mais qu'est ce
qu'elle veut lever autant que je peux
revenir sur wikileaks si vous avez fermé
ma sorcière bien-aimée à lyon à oui je
suis père alors c'est ça c'est un regard
d'être bouge tes narines
ah ouais mais ça me dit ça m'angoisse
mme el poussah narines c'est une
extraterrestre h demain je vais faire ce
faire les oreilles ouais ouais
ah ouais c'est à dire qu'elle a des
muscles très important au niveau du
visage mais je le sais je sais
jean-michel vos questions vous savez
faire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ap
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais tu pourrais fauteuil qu'ils
apprennent à une carte ses narines
inquiète pas mais klaus franz a après on
lui passera après